foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Friday February 17th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
the internet is not always a safe space
especially for children parents have
long worried that Predators could Target
their kids on platforms where they spend
a lot of time and create relationships
that Guardians know nothing about
now law enforcement is warning that Tick
Tock has emerged as the biggest fastest
growing danger zone yet joining me to
discuss how parents police and the
platform are trying to keep Kids Safe is
our reporter tonell Hobbs hi tonnelle
thanks for joining us hello so it seems
like since the dawn of the internet
there have been adults who've tried to
have improper relationships with minors
using a variety of platforms I mean chat
rooms messaging services social media
platforms what is it about Tick Tock
that makes law enforcement so concerned
obviously it's a big platform and it's
very fast growing and it's also the
algorithm Tick Tock has tick tock's
algorithm is unusually strong and when I
say that it's basically you can watch
for instance dancing teens
a few of those in Tick Tock will just
start sending you video after video more
and more of dancing teens
what the law enforcement say is that
pedophiles really liking videos
basically they don't have to do much
Tick Tock just feeds them video after
video of this content and they just
could sit there and watch I'm sure a lot
of our listeners are aware that Tick
Tock is very popular with younger users
but can you just give us a sense of like
how popular it is with young people well
it's the top place where young people
spend more time social media site than
any other every day they spend an
average of 107 minutes per day on tick
tock and that's more than any other
platform right that's a significant
chunk of anybody's day what has Tick
Tock said it's doing to try and keep
young users on its platform safe
basically Tick Tock for users 13 and
older they're on the main platform and
there's still some limitations for them
for instance if you're under 16 you
can't direct message now if you're under
Tick Tock it's a different experience
for those kids because they can't do
everything like they can't share videos
or they can't message other users or
maintain followers so that's just some
of the safeguards for under 13. here's
the problem and this is just not with
Tick Tock when it comes to some of these
safety measures it's dependent on the
user being honest about their age
kids are smart if they want to make
themselves 18 or 17 they can you can
make yourself older by changing your
date of birth and that's what's
happening and kids ought to do that so
when you have these safety measures that
are dependent on the honesty of a young
person entering their date of birth
that's when a lot of those measures
don't work has tiktok commented on these
issues they say that they have put in
these safety measures to do this and
they're still
continually improve it on their safety
measures Susie Loftus who is Tick tock's
Global head of risk and response
operations trust and safety she said
that when Tick Tock becomes aware of
such content they take immediate action
to remove it terminate the account and
Report the cases to the proper
authorities and then also a tick tock
spokesperson said that the platform uses
technology to screen post they also look
at captions and comments
and items that race concerns those go to
a human screener so they actually go to
a human person
they declined to disclose how many human
screeners they have you know they get
billions of videos uploaded
each month and there's some in law
enforcement that
question how are they able to screen
that many videos with all those captions
and all the comments just to be clear
this isn't hypothetical right I mean you
looked at one specific instance can you
tell us about it so basically you have a
situation where a 42 year old man from
Alabama he uploaded a lot to tick tock
and basically lip singing
it had a lot of depressive thoughts he
talked about suicide
and a 14 year old girl in Texas
responded
and they just started having a
conversation and a lot of their
conversation I could see they were
exchanging these romantic notes that
were just visible to everyone on
platform
and there were actually other commenters
and they were accusing this 42 year old
man being inappropriate they were saying
he was talking to her and all kinds of
things and this continued and basically
what happened is they started talking
indirect messages mind you she's 14
years old
technically she should not have been
able to access direct messages but she
was yeah she lives in Texas he ended up
coming to Texas tonnelle that man was
later indicted on charges related to
alleged sexual assaults of a child has
he said anything about those charges I
went to the jail to talk to him to
interview him
and initially he denied doing anything
sexual with her
but as we talked he admitted to doing
some sexual things to her
he did say he did not have intercourse
but there were other sexual things that
he said that he did have we heard from
the young girl or from her family at all
her mother is obviously just devastated
about everything
she said it's just every parent's
nightmare
and she's obviously concerned about the
lasting impact on her daughter what has
Tick Tock said about this incident
occurring on its platform and about a 14
year old violating their own policies
and using direct messaging Tick Tock
declined the comment on this case but
they did say after
I called and asked him about it they did
take down his profile and reported him
to the authorities and law enforcement
what have they said about the incident
they just give me basic details about
the rest because it's involving a minor
they haven't like talked about it but
definitely law enforcement are very
concerned about minors on The Tick Tock
platform they are very concerned about
the platform itself because they just
feel that it's too easy for pedophiles
to get on the site
to find youngsters to contact them and
to groom them through the site all right
we'll have to leave it there tonnelle
Hobbs investigative reporter for the
Wall Street Journal thank you so much
for joining us for this conversation
thank you and that's it for Tech news
briefing this week heads up we'll be off
on Monday for the holiday but we'll be
back Tuesday with more Tech news tnb's
producer is Julie Chang our supervising
producer is Melanie Roy and our
executive producer is Chris sinsley I'm
your host Zoe Thomas thanks for
listening and have a great weekend
[Music]
thank you